so I'm delighted to welcome everyone to
this exciting event the title of the
presentation today is fountain house a
working community that brings hope to
mind it will be a three white press
presentation by John Rivera as a member
of founder house
Alan Doyle who's the director of
training and education at fountain the
house and an assistant professor here
and who has worked very closely in a
very interesting project with folks at
fountain house so and I would like to
introduce to this event so I'm going to
read because I don't want to miss
anything in terms of your introduction
so John Rivera joined fountain house in
1996 he holds a BA in public
administration from John Jay College of
Criminal Justice and currently he's a
part-time resident counselor at fountain
house he's a member of the wellness unit
and a volunteer mentor for what's
referred to as the unity project which
outreaches to youth and young adults
dealing with mental health issues John
is also an advocate for mental health
recovery recently he joined Allen and
others in a panel at the 21st world
congress of social psychiatry in Lisbon
Portugal to present the fountain house
recovery model and integrated care Alan
Doyle is the director of training and
education at fountain house where he
oversees the be the fountain house
Institute which is an international
training forum for the working community
approach to psychiatric recovery was
originally developed at fountain house
and has since been replicated worldwide
this is really significant previously he
was the assistant director for a
regional vocational school in Long
Island providing occupational training
to adults and high school students and
literacy education to immigrants and
while he was there he created an
alternative high school for disaffected
youth
he's served as the liaison of the
Massachusetts state commissioner
Commission to the state's congressional
delegation in DC and he taught Latin in
the Great Neck Public Schools so yeah he
holds a doctorate in educational
planning and it's social and social
policy from the Harvard University
School of Education and he's the
co-author hot off the press fountain
house creating community and mental
health practice from the Columbia
University Press in November 2013 and
Fang Kai Chen is an assistant professor
at the CSS W and a faculty member in our
AG PP curriculum her research focuses on
service delivery implementation and
dissemination of community-based
psychiatric rehab programs she's
interested in identifying elements of
best practices in community mental
health to enhance assist the system's
capacity to collaborate with individuals
and their informal support systems to
mitigate the impact of mental health of
mental illness I'm sorry
and again thank a has worked very
closely with her collaborators at
fountain house and that's the project
they're going to present and then I
would also like to thank the AG PP
committee the student AG P peacock
caucus and McCann oakley's Department
the communications department student
services for us because it really takes
a village to create a presentation like
this so that was an eloquent
introduction appreciate it very much
both John and I are very appreciative of
the invitation to speak to you today
about fountain house Allen reminded me
we were here three years ago thank you
to myself yeah one if I'm gonna say the
same thing but and also I wanted to
thank very much Fang pay who invited us
and felt it was important that we were
able to talk about fountain house to you
today
I was fully introduced basically I am an
educator who now works as in Social Work
and have been doing this work for about
the last 14 years now so most of you
know about fountain house is a place on
West 47th Street in New York that was
started in 1948 by a group of
activations from Rockland State Hospital
they were it was also started by wound
by the name of Elizabeth squirming horn
and on the way over here I mentioned to
John that there's a squirming building
and so she was really part of this large
family well-known family in New York
City of which there's a building on
Fifth Avenue and a big 18th Street and
of course in the book and you have this
that the subway stops Cameron Street so
and she was very much in the tradition I
think of the settlement house workers
and the way I think about her is she's
really created a settlement house for
people with psychiatric illnesses by
creating fountain house and she was the
creator one of the creators have found
out there's a thousand members at
fountain house so there's a lot of
relationships that are go on at fountain
house a variety of a whole whole bevy of
relationships that are involved there we
have residents for I think close to 500
people I think we are the largest
residential facility psychiatric
residential facility in the state oddly
we have an art gallery of form as I was
introduced we have an international
training institute we're currently doing
innovations in social cooperatives and
young adults and John is on one of those
innovations that we're dealing as a
reach out program to individuals who are
young and who are first experiencing
their first psychotic break and
of associates among them are employers
and that some of you might be familiar
with the TE program the transitional
employment Employment Program
so we've always worked in partnership
with other groups this is not we're not
a lone ranger we're not all alone but
we've depended significantly for others
to to accomplish our goals
and finally we have a vision and that
vision is about recovery and social
integration for our members but today I
don't really don't want to talk about
the place I want to talk about fountain
house as an idea and I'll just tell you
a little story of how this began about
eight years ago it may know students who
come to fountain houses interns that I
recall this one intern New York
University and when she returned back
from one of her classes the professor
said well what did you do today so this
is sort of a low if you know found house
is a sort of a loaded question because
of course she said well you know I work
in horticulture and we were putting out
flowers in each of the rooms and and I'm
sure she mentioned how she cleaned the
bathroom at the end of the day with the
member and the professor was really
incensed that that she was spending her
time this way I mean this was a she was
supposed to be educated as a
professional and he clearly saw this as
a complete waste of time
for somebody of her level and when she
told me this story and she was she told
me about the incident in class it was
rather public display that would and
when I thought about it I said you know
there's something wrong with this
dialogue that's occurring and that I
felt the professor missed something but
I also felt that we weren't doing our
job
in helping people to understand exactly
what it is that we do at fountain house
and eventually took a while mention I
thought of it as a model but at least
initially I said you know it's probably
the way we're talking about it because
words and names are very important they
help us to sort of situate what we're
looking at and we I really believe
personally that you don't see things
that you don't have names for somehow
you're looking at it but if you don't
have the name for it you know you really
don't take it in so it started me really
on a quest that resulted in the book
about about first of war to think of how
we're going to conceive a fountain house
it's differently from you know just sort
of putting out plants or caring for
plants and and we came up with the idea
of community and a working community
it's also a professional practice which
I call social practice and finally it's
a vision which has as I mentioned in the
beginning there's over 300 imitations of
fountain house throughout the world and
there's probably a lot more of varying
degrees of people who claim to be part
of a clubhouse or found us so so but we
didn't come to this language right away
historically fountain house really
started with a group of members and they
started the Juanes society that we are
not alone Society
it's a group of ex-patients who were
formed with Elizabeth's perma horn who I
mentioned earlier and they really
thought of the way they thought of
fountain house was sort of as a social
club I'm sure all of you are familiar
with investigations that occur in Little
Italy and they're still after mafia and
they're these gentlemen are walking
and whispering to one another in front
of their social club so but these social
clubs go back to the 30s the 40s you
know that part of it was all part of an
immigrant population and the these clubs
became the way of integrating the
immigrant population they promised
housing and certainly one of promised
housing education companionship
employment this was the type of thing
that the Juana group would go up to
Rockland State and talk to other
patients when you leave come see us and
it was essentially a peer-to-peer model
that they were they were applying in
1955 John beard enters the stage for a
fountain house he was the fourth
executive director at fountain house he
came and he he actually worked there
till his death in 1982 prior to coming
to fountain house he was working outside
of Detroit City in a hospital that was
called Eloise and there he became
enamored of the work of a psychiatrist
who felt very very assuredly that that
there was something something really
healthy and productive about people with
mental illness despite the fact of how
they either acted or where it was that
we're able to to behave in or or
accomplish things within Eloise and he
introduced a therapeutic approach called
activity group therapy which they he and
John beard and also the psych
psychologists that worked with them
whose name I just forgot Victor Gertz
all the three of them they were like a
team there's a word for it in in
hospitals where you give form sort of a
medical team
go in and to work with a group of people
rather than just an individual so they
they felt very strongly that that there
was this healthy part of the person and
they really wanted to investigate I
thought how they can address people's
capacities for for accomplishment rather
than to study the illness and they
developed these norms or attendance one
was we have to get them do normal things
like they would play play different
games or they'd have plays they would
make popcorn together they would paint
but in any case it was essentially when
you think about it was basically a
strength-based approach that they were
taking they felt very strongly that they
had to respect the individuals choice
they developed the coaching role for the
first staff in terms of how they would
relate to patients and finally they felt
there had to be some sort of movement
towards the outside and social inclusion
and they formed the it's essentially
they form the early transitional
employment and they really felt this was
how a recovery system should work beard
then came to fountain house and he
simply applied these principles to what
was a day program and they and that's
how he referred to it
there's the day program what do you what
do you do during the day you go to work
all right so he sort of created a work
day as a day program with social and
recreational activities in the evenings
and on weekends so he simply said well
what's normal in society it's normal to
go to work five days a week from 9:00 to
5:00
that's what fountain house will be you
come to work five days a week and and
essentially when you look at you know
going to work or something it's it's
really a task group methodology which is
which is I feel is very rich in terms of
the applicant
patience that it offers to people with
mental illness first of all it gets
purpose right away we're all we're
together we have to do something whether
it's we have to we have a hydroponics
area now we're growing our own food so
well you have to figure out well how do
we do this so the purpose becomes very
clear there's different roles and
responsibilities and here again when you
start thinking about taking
responsibility for our particular
activity within a group it's really what
bandura talks about as an active
experience experience it is the most
important component of somebody
establishing their the self this feeling
of self-efficacy and motivation there
are structured relationships there's
modeling which is once again a major
tenant of bandura
in building a person's sense of
self-efficacy there's also a planning
that goes on within task groups so that
you've got to start getting into issues
around empowerment and shared leadership
and finally there's learning that occurs
you all stop and say how'd we do today
you can all congratulate one up we've
the mill came out it was there wasn't
too much salt in the soup you know you
can feel good about this thank you so
and so who made the soup Norman you know
so you have that basic sense of a
feedback loop learning from your
learning from your intervention seeing
how you could do it better
congratulating each other
if you've accomplished it and that's
what I mean about task group methodology
is it it is a wonderful wonderful tool
in our hands when we're dealing with
this issue of mental health recovery
so essentially what what what beer did
at fountain house was he took this
activity group therapy which is which
was basically a psychiatric intervention
and he secularized it for with within a
normal turbine environment when we're
down on 47th Street in New York and said
how are we going to set this up with the
purpose of
supporting people and their recovery
from mental illness we called a working
community that's the word we gave to it
now when you think about this in terms
of what was going on around fountain
house during this period of time 1948 to
the present well during the 1960's which
is about 15 years after fountain house
started
you have the institutionalization starts
to occur there's a half a million people
who are in the state mental state mental
hospital system most of whom by now are
out of that system I think there's about
75,000 people something like that and
and there was a change in understanding
how we treat this issue of mental
illness that it the hospital isn't the
salt or the asylum it's really the
asylum is not the approach we should
take people can live in society and we
and a lot of the push for
deinstitutionalization actually happened
within a legal context around least
restrictive environment and we've gone
to almost the opposite end of the
extreme in terms of least restrictive
environment however think about this
no grammatically anybody know what the
real percentage of employment is among
people with severe mental illness yeah
10 percent maybe 15 if it really good so
when we start looking at you know the
statistics do you know what the largest
mental health institution I live in
Suffolk County in Commack New York but
there used to be three mental hospitals
within distance of my house within five
miles we were probably the largest
mental health gathering place in the
entire world up until the 1950s yet I
get hardened
at Kings Park Deer Park and and also
Brentwood and they were all there must
have been 30,000 people together who are
in these huge massive institutions
they're all empty now they're all empty
buildings now so but do you know what
the largest mental health institution is
now in Suffolk County prison so
essentially what we've done what we've
done is we've taken a base but is
basically an illness and we've
criminalized it in terms of our
institutional care
now and NPR was doing this same thing in
this Chicago and I think it's the Cook
County Jail is the largest institution
for people with mental illness so we
that this is our programmatic
achievement of the institutionalization
I just mentioned this because it's at
the same time that we're to introduce
this idea of fountain house and and what
we call the working community because it
really created a place where if what we
believe is the real issue facing us when
people leave mental institutions and
they go into society we believe the real
issue is so is this social isolation -
when we when we use the word community
by the way we don't refer to it as a
place we refer to it as a system of
relationships all right so there are you
know people talk about oh you have to be
in community and everything that's nice
but you can be alone in community and if
you talk to parents of families who have
somebody with mental illness they are
very aware of how how their sons and
daughters are isolated they live in the
bedroom they have very few friends so
this is your social isolate isolate I I
civilization isolation sorry
we believe is the fundamental issue that
that we're trying to address and that's
why community is such an important word
important model to really think about as
part of the treatment methodology
because essentially what community says
is that no no you don't have to isolate
people or leave them isolate you can
actually have people with mental illness
can live in community they can
contribute to the community they can
have relations within the community we
also feel that it's not just a place of
work where you go and you have tasks and
everything where the that sort of
drained of all emotional contact DOM
house is a highly relational place then
the tasks that are there which was the
real problem when you go back to that
initial story that I told you when when
and when the student went back to class
she didn't talk about modeling she
didn't talk about coaching she didn't
talk about consensus decision-making I
mean all the tap all the real strategies
that are employed in order to create a
community that makes it amenable for
people in recovery for mental illness
she talked about the things they did and
that's really meant about language is
that nobody saw what was really going on
and then that's why that really why we
wrote the book we were trying to figure
out well what do you really say to
people what's really going on here so
and just a fountain house and I'll do
this rather quickly
we really believe there's a very special
way we set up at this community there
are certain principles that we embed
within this community first that which
is represented here I just don't speak
John speaks with me we went to Portugal
together we're going to Switzerland
together as well this year we were
invited back he did he was invited back
that he invited me to come all right
so John was the invitation okay so so
but that shows you that that we don't do
things without numbers why because we
feel that members are a part of society
members can do what what I do members
can do we do it together and that's the
statement we're trying to make that we
that that people with mental serious
mental illness can live in society
and be successful there has to be choice
at the base of it and freedom to choose
and that we do this at this is a
collaborative we are not a consumer run
organization we are a collaborative
organization and we day one we always
think about that we do this as
collaborative model we also have I feel
that there's a professional practice
that's it which is at the base of our
work in which we really divide up the
two functions of of our work as a staff
person or anybody even members who are
trying to help set up a clubhouse or a
fountain house there's a design aspect
that has to be addressed as I said it's
not just a place of work it's a highly
emotional and relational environment and
therefore it demands certain skills and
very easy one to understand if this is
going to be a collaborative venture
let's do it through consensus
decision-making so you ought to know how
if you're gonna hire somebody at
fountain house
you ought to they ought to know how to
do consensus decision-making that's a
strategy that modeling that you have to
be willing to break up work and show how
it's done
and and the modeling and there are other
things too but that's examples of it but
we also believe that as part of the
collaboration that there are personal
relationships that we set up and I love
this especially when you send students
from our school as a social worker to
fountain house and they say well and
this issue comes up about relationships
and about you know can it can can you
see each other after work that was one
do you give you a telephone number out
of which in some schools they're taught
not to do that because you have to keep
it for professional distance this idea
of distance what I say is this we we
dismiss all those prohibitions okay
that's not what we're into what we
believe is we
to get people as close as we can without
touching that is our understanding of
distance and you have to have a highly
controlled environment to do that right
but we believe that that relationship
that you set up is very important in the
recovery process and we have and you
deal with that basically as a coach you
know you're coaching people in terms of
their own skills once again it's
strength based your coaching in terms of
skills so it's things like that where so
these are all skills which I would which
I feel is called social practice it's
actually a word I got from a Danish
researcher who was just observing what
goes on in a clubhouse it's a word that
was used in the 1950s at that time it
was called social treatment and it was
one of the founding principles of
fountain house that it was part of
million therapy that was going on
throughout the 40s and 30s 4050 s in the
in the United States and they talked
about social treatment where people
would just do ordinary normal things
people who had mental illness and that's
how you would support their recovery and
so you would help in socializing helping
them to socialize in a normalized
environment so in thinking about this
word community as a very powerful way of
understanding how mental health practice
should or a mental health agency should
be practicing what we did is first of
all align ourselves deeply within both
psychiatry through activity group
therapy which goes back to group work a
Freud which and it sort of splits
between treatment the task groups and
treatment groups I guess is a way of
doing it and we took the test group
route rather than the treatment group
room treatment group route which
would be more of a talk therapy but it
had this sense we come out of a very
strong psychiatric you we also come out
of a very strong Social Work review menu
in terms of the settlement houses cotton
house is a house like a settlement house
I mean even our name we were started by
a settlement house on 46th Street who
gave us the money to start and so we
have also these other roots that come
from Social Work strength based
empowerment all these the language that
we use and values that we espouse are
very central to work in good work what
is considered exemplary work in Social
Work and what we do actually is take
something like strength based or
empowerment say empowerment and we
actually figure out how to actualize
that in reality so for us empowerment
means we do consensus decision-making
empowerment means that we don't hire
enough staff and that we always are
working with as a result have to work
with members in order for the work of
the house to get done so we take these
values of empowerment and strength based
and we try to figure out very practical
everyday mundane ways of doing this like
you know we're together we're gonna make
sure all the flowers are done today you
know and they're fed properly and stuff
like that so and just in conclusion I
know one of the things that happens for
me when I go especially if I'm dealing
policymakers they well found had that
sort of old thing that's old style you
know cuz and we are old
okay we're sixty-five years old I guess
and and so it's it's a tough thing it's
a tough sell to be old I guess and but I
just simply say I just simply say look
you know we hold the same values as the
recovery method which is a very in way
of you know talking today or the
recovery methodology that people can
live and thrive in the community that
that this is that hope is is is central
to a recovery theory not participe that
you're always going to be sick that
choice and you know nothing about us
without us these are all the mantras and
these are all if if you you know if you
look at found the house and the history
of thumb these are all things that we
started with these this was sort of
basic 101 thousand hours to that we
we're not just a consumer society okay
we are somebody we actually asked
members to contribute that is our
primary goal as part of this
contribution we do help members with
their needs but people don't come to us
to get a job to get housing when they
come to us and say what would you like
to do you know I don't even say what
would you like to do I say hey I need
help can you help me today okay I gotta
get this done you're the only one here
can you just follow me around he knows
so we're into not a consumer society we
are into a contributing society once
again demonstrating that members can
live just like everybody else doing very
important work in our society that is
helping their peers live and not in the
hospital anymore not in the asylum but
within this new methodology that we
believe very strongly that they can
survive in in and we've practiced this
since 1948 so do you have any questions
practitioner and I was thinking about
more systems more structural level
wondering what fountain house does or
what as a community you do to increase
that 10% employment outside of fountain
house or to generalize these kinds of
principles so that so that people who
live in fountain house have a more
friendly environment outside
as well so I think you're probably
familiar with the transitional
employment I'm not going to go into that
our latest venture because we're looking
at the stats over saying well we're not
getting anywhere with just transitional
employment and supported employee you
know the regular and full employment is
sort of a troika you know so what we've
really started to look at our social
cooperatives where members actually
become the owners as well as the workers
within businesses and we've been doing
this for about five six years now and
the more we do it this is not easy work
there's no easy answer here but I
personally believe very strongly that we
have to go much further in doing this
the Europeans have have moved in this
area as well and certainly if we're
going to work with people in India and
in Africa we in the same way in New York
City you cannot conceive of know if
you're going to do social work that you
got to have housing otherwise people
freeze to death right so in New York
City we sort of got it that we have to
do something about housing and
homelessness not that everybody's has
housing but at least we do something
unlike LA where because of the weather
they don't have to do anything so they
don't then people are just left on the
street all over the place okay but it
yeah so I when I say well if we're going
to go to Africa and not have people
chained to trees and all this other
bizarre stuff that goes on how people
are really treated in the inhumane ways
people are treated if they have
schizophrenia that we're gonna have to
go with jobs figure out this job's way
of and and their real jobs and that's
why we've started to explore this idea
of social cooperatives that first of all
it's it's sort of interesting for
members to say well you're the owner now
and they can also control their time see
if you're if you're if you're an
employee you can't
your time it's whatever the employer
tells you it's your time but if you are
the owner
you control your time this is very
important for our members because they
can't work certain amount of hours or
they're gonna lose their their health
insurance they're going to lose their
benefit you know the the the Social
Security benefits that they receive so
they can restrict their hours and still
be the owner which i think is one of the
real great benefits of thinking this way
we do it as a group because why because
that's what we're good at
we're good at groups that that is our
technique that we you know and that's
where we're moving for the future is to
look at policy changes yeah there be
great policy changes our first one I
start with the second question we first
had a little una we started a it was a
luncheonette and it was for a housing a
public housing project in New York City
and we ran it and it was called La Luna
now they were playing out of several
ideas first of all it was called the
Silver Moon or half moon the name of the
house the residents was called happy one
so they took Luna but they were also
playing on the word Luna for lunatics
and stuff like that so
so they took la luna which was sort of
the moon okay and they worked for about
a year and a half and then then the city
cancelled the contract and then we went
to the city is all we didn't know you
know it's like the city you know could
be supporting this type of intervention
they certainly had paid for it because
we were doing a business which was
helping out in and and then they pulled
the rug under out from underneath us and
you know also is bad business planning
because we only had one contract so when
that one contract when we lost their
business but now we're we've we got into
the bedbug business for a while because
that was a big thing here you have to
sort of think of things a niche and to
be to be honest with you we we're very
Jim Nana Berg has been very good he was
a professor here and he was very he's
done a lot of work in this area and he
got them guiding us back about how to go
about doing this
you sort of need a niche area where
unlike the Europeans the Europeans they
believe that they sort of believe in
employment and therefore they will make
employment for people and they would
fund social cooperatives the United
States doesn't believe in employment so
it so you have to make it much more yeah
it from a social policy point of view
it's it's a very different way I think
so we have to think of the hardest thing
is trying to find the right niche to
work in and and and therefore you as a
policy piece you do need social
investors and right now fountain house
is a social investor and we're trying to
attract social and people who are so
well social investors have a long-term
you know like it's not three years and
the demonstration project is a success
this we need 8 to 10 years to pull this
stuff off and I don't know if government
is ready to invest this way both because
of work you know that how we think about
work but I think that's the real policy
and it should be an advocacy issue I
don't know if I'm getting at but I think
that you need from a it's not really a
policy issue but you need a social
investor to keep it going by the way
fountain house does not pay anybody we
provide and we give loans that are paid
back once the company starts to make
money so we've tried to say as well as
much as we can as a you know so that the
the company has to really be real and
exist on its own and supply something
the market needs cooperatives yes the
staff are only there is there is no
staff on within the coop
it's a wholly-owned there is a God but
we do no no no no I they the paid staff
there are paid staff and even here we're
not a purist we we're absurd of moving
that there must be some sort of guidance
from the staff we're trying to work that
out so that you know some people are
very purist about all he can only have
members together and and we're just
trying to make things right and and not
go with any of these ideological ways of
going about doing something and so we're
really struggling with what should be
the staff role so there is a staff paid
paid staff for all but they are not part
of the company they are there as a on an
advisory committee there's advisory
committee and they're on the advisory
committee now they know I mean all the
members that know the staff so that it's
not like this this is an unknown
quantity and they work together and then
doing it that energy question about yeah
I'll stay afterwards
just want to thank everyone for having
us here today it's a pleasure to be here
Alan invited me to come here and say
personally in ma and I was actually what
do I want to share as a consumer as a
member of fountain house as a person in
recovery and wasn't quite sure what I
was gonna say but we'll see where it
goes so I mean III think like in terms
of like recovery I think we have to ask
what it means for an individual as
facilitators and in the Social Work
field is it what does it mean for you
you know I mean when you work with
someone who may have a mental illness
and either in talk therapy or an agency
and stuff like that and when you cease I
mean with the education and the
methodologies it's like how do you
define recovering I mean what do you see
actually I'm gonna ask someone your
student back there and so let your
student how would you how would you
define recovery I mean for let's say a
mental health consumer xs-1 bipolar
schizo affective schizophrenia like how
would you
here in working with people but however
they define you know feeling healthier
feeling like they whatever their no it's
fine that's something I'm actually happy
to hear that because I think you know I
found house like sometimes because I was
in 12th or Fe for many years and it was
helpful to a certain degree and I
realize sometimes in those like
structured settings like you're there
and someone is there and by virtue of
being there like you feel like there's
something wrong with you but or else you
wouldn't be there and you feel a sense
that you have to like there's an
expectation of standard of what is
normal like okay are you thinking is
there in a way are you acting a certain
way you're speaking a certain way and
I'm here to try to help you act a
certain way to speak a certain way to
think a certain way and that's can be
very frustrating or and maybe not as
hopeful in it
I suppose the fountain house like if you
come to found house anyone who you may
have like a little difficulty like
knowing whose staff and who's number
depending I mean some people you know
struggle a little bit more but sometimes
it happens to people you're not even
really sure and and I think I found
house when you come in as a member
coming through the doors there's no
definition of recovery there's no one
saying well okay we this is what
recovery looks like this is what we want
one see from you you kinda like thrown
into the mix of activity there's a
inherent need to be needed which is
really important because I mean it's
that's so much in my background but some
of the young people that in that unity
group that was mentioned you can see the
lot of traumatic stress in their
background growing up like really like
deeper trails by primary caretakers and
the love emotion was really mixed with a
lot of other chaotic things and then
just close down you know and sometimes I
think you know what are we dealing with
you know brains aren't inherently broken
or water or hot sauce it really wound it
sometimes I ask myself and sometimes I
actually think the heart is the center
of consciousness spirit of consciousness
and the brain is just the limb
and these symptoms are just a really
gallant admirin coping mechanisms that
we have to try to deal with some really
difficult issues so and I think you know
element is really stressing like the
relationships how we're kind of like
very close and I think what you get is
like a region of the heart that found a
house trust I think is the secret to
staff work a member is much more easily
readable I think then sometimes in
psychotherapy because they're you then
they're not this figure that maybe you
know can be very difficult time dealing
with you just like you and there is a
region of the heart where you needed
your respected your acknowledged or
accepted accepted even people who maybe
are acting a little bit strange or you
know you just who you are and somehow in
that mix it's I know I'm not having the
background is in social social work or
psychology and like that but somehow
there's a magic in that in that in those
relationships I think that I've formed a
real a magic because that like we think
a little recovery is like you know if
some of the students like had to break
when they were 19 and he's going back to
school and getting degree are they
working
what type of work are they doing you
know so we had like these societal
standards but sometimes it's just the
capacity to freely give love and receive
love I think is my definition of
recovery and if you can do that the work
will be there and the school will be
there because you'll have that like a
reintegration of the soul you'll have
the whole miss back and I think does a
good job we're not perfect but we do do
a good job of that thank you
well actually thank you very much for
thank Alan and John very much for giving
us a different perspective of funhouse
and this is actually my pleasure to
really work with the two of you to
contribute a little bit about my
understanding of funding house and to
think about it more from the social work
perspective and you bring the my slides
up so what I'm trying to do with my
section here is really to think about
ready to talk about sort of an inner
work within from my house and so I think
Alan and Joan help us really to
understand what the model is about and
what the thinking behind it what it what
the experiences is like in from the
house and I think very importantly is
especially for Social Work students and
faculty or together is really to
understand or to think use fun houses as
an example to think about whether there
are actually alternatives to what we
usually talk about in terms of treatment
therapy that we that can really for us
to do to be really helpful for people
with severe mental illness so I wanted
actually to start look back into a
literature a little bit you know I'm a
researcher so unfortunately or
surprisingly about from an aspect one of
the things that I've found one is that
one of the things that's interesting is
it's long you know it has been low
documented in terms of practices as a
generalist practice and the way to
describe staff member in from the house
is really a journalist and because they
are doing a variety of programmatic
areas which is true and I will tell you
a lot about my experiences there and
then it uses information and knowledge
from multiple disciplines and it's work
on multiple sister lovers are
simultaneously and just one thing I
wanted to
while Alan was talking about before in
mentioning about John beer and his very
first experiences in the hospital
working a team and working on a group
activity therapy was actually in his
second year internship as a social
worker students do them so what an
inspiration so think about you know
students here might be the next jump
here in the years to come
so be creative and be yourself and think
things on your own feet
and the other part about the research is
actually a lot to figure out who are the
staff members at firehouse and there are
quite I mean a little bit more it
studies being done there and so some go
for someone for the like a personality
route so they actually kinetic
personality test and so it turned out
you know um flexibility spontaneously
spontaneously and enthusiasm are
important to be to be a staff member at
common house so it looks like it's
pretty much needs to be accurate to be
able to work it f on the house but not
quite so I would tell you what I saw and
by the other party is ready to have a
very optimistic attitude about a
recovery that would be definitely
helpful to working from the house and to
be able to uh to also count sort of
buying to the idea to be about founding
house they would be very helpful working
in in the clubhouse environment and add
to and I think you know is really the
conclusion from the research is it now
needs to be a match between the personal
style and conviction and beliefs to be
effective in a cop house environment and
what about car house practices it's even
less information there but there is one
study particularly 'king at what are the
concepts that related to building a
sense of calm
and those are four there are four
particular concepts that the researchers
like picked up one year still really
solid in that develop affiliation a
sense of affiliation and support for
members and the other one is to create
the shared experiences with members in a
cop house and then also there are some
characteristics of cop house
organization that helps to make the make
a sense of community that would include
for example the flexibility of the
structures and strict schedules and so
on so forth and there is a first concept
is to really make the task and the Ross
functional meaningful within the house
and that's you know I that's that's at
this to my till extent that I can search
that's pretty much what sells about the
practices but there are actually a lot
of early writings about tootie's try to
describe what it looks like in to work
in a cop house model or in actually I
shouldn't actually attribute list she
found the house because a lot of writing
is actually about funding house and some
of the articles are actually founded
newsletters in fact so it's really
describing this particular organization
and these are some examples one is to
really describe it as more of an art
than a science and I think in that
particular article he also described a
lot of paradoxes that staff member has
to face are that would include and then
you find that okay increase test its
exercising leadership in order to give
it away and that will include accepting
help from members in order to support
members and I work include allowing
themselves to be inspired and moved by
members in order to do good work so
let's
you know more an artwork rather than
science and the other piece is about
relationships and the work order day
which is the way that people describe
the work I mean the day program for
important kora is really well we call it
a work order day and those are those two
components are actually very much
intertwined and people have our
relationship because of the way that
people structure work on Thursday there
and the relationships is really rooted
in that kind of form and that kind of
mode of interaction and a surpise I
think also interesting I wanted to
highlight is to really to adapt a peer
role and that would require the staff
members to reduce the hierarchical power
structure and in I mean in a typical
environment the staff member or the
professionals would being a higher power
status but here we require it to be even
out and to really try not to hide behind
the self protective distance from the
members and so that's another piece that
I find very interesting okay and given
there is such limited literature out
there in comparison to this fantastic
model so that really gave me in treating
I wanted to really learn more about it
and especially I think before in the
introduction I've been doing research
about direct practices in community
mental health programs and this is
certainly a model that I definitely
don't want to miss so I had a very good
fortune a lot of support and help and
then I last year I had this research
idea and very fortunately I was able to
really do it and so my focus is really
trying to go into the black box of
father house and trying to understand
staff members role in function and what
kind of practice approaches and
strategies they are they are trying to
do and also trying to identify you know
since there
saying there are some characteristics of
an individual that would be helpful
let's see if flats in one of those and
also the Cara sticks of this
organization what one is helpful for
this to happen
ah so I started my study in November
last year and so it's a almost a fact
five months and almost six six months
now and my approach is doing participant
observation in-depth interviews and
archival reviews and I actually just
tell you last night I can't believe it
so I actually have been in funding house
for 37 visits now in 37 seven days and I
have spent about two hundred and twenty
eight hours so far and I had conducted
24 interviews with staff members 7
interviews with supervisors or union
leaders and tough interviews with
members and and I think what I'm going
to share today because it's your ongoing
so those member are still counting so
what I'm going to do today is not so
much to describe the findings of the
study by really drawing from the things
that I had saw have seen and experienced
from a participant observation because I
was I was really fortunately being able
to become a volunteer to that tool from
the house and was able to be part of the
the world order day and and in that way
I'm able to experience as a newcomer to
the house and I also was instructed as a
volunteer I should mimic the staff
members roles as I was able to try some
things and how I wouldn't say exactly
the same experiences but I think close
enough and so but by the way I really
have to say I had a newfound
appreciation for students here because I
really see this as my internship and
having something to share for years
Tuvia what do you work here and school
and to go to the field and I'm average I
actually go there one day or two days a
week and sometimes three days yeah I
have a newfound appreciation so and so
here we go
so what I'm going to talk about today is
our focusing on two areas actually one
is that the rap practice from those
staff members and the other part is
really about organization and the
programming and in practice area I'm
trying going to really highlight
professional use of self to develop a
genuine relationship and the other part
is the practices and community building
and program part I will focus on
flexibility and openness and also the
intentionality of this organization so
so the professional use of self when I
realize this that as we hear from the
previous presentations it is a lot of
interactions between the staff and the
members and in a very very unique way
and so what I intended to do or to see
there is to see how that really looks
like you know we can read about it and
I'll give an example where the
internship the interest wouldn't really
couldn't really describe what's going on
so that's actually one of the areas that
I'm trying to focus on and trying to
sort of analyze what's going on there so
when so there are the lists here are the
areas where the staff members really
need to use themselves as the tool and
one thing is to engage members and how
do we do this and so when the staff try
to use themselves to engage members a
lot of times they use their personal
aspects of for example their personal
interest so they talked about sports and
some South staff has a background in
arts also they talk about arts
talk about music and so it's not just
too limited to their professional role
so - it's really - you know we are all
people we are all individuals in persons
we have all our own life stories we
share that and use that as a way to
engage members and then the other part
is really just be yourselves so John was
talking about you are you feel like in
you are you know they are as a person
you can be as generous or or saying TQ
that's the same for staff members you
know you know someone can be loud be
loud
I saw many things someone can be a
little bit shy be shy and because of
that it really creates a whole mix of
different kinds of receptors how do I
describe it and so any member coming
with all different kind of carrot sticks
backgrounds they have someone to attach
to and that's the beauty of fun a house
so it really encouraged you to be
yourself and I was doing her to be
myself - but not this is not to say you
sort of put aside all the you know
ethical consideration no and and I think
if anything I think it actually puts
individuals in a even higher ground you
have a much higher bar to reach because
you have to figure out what are you
really to be a professional working with
people with severe mental illness and so
this so it really puts you on your toes
all the time to figure out who you
really are as a society there and the
other part is trying to reduce power
differential and I think from the two
presenters before we hear a lot about
you know working side-by-side and
involve members but what does it really
take for you to do it it takes I think
for the staff members to be willing to
be vulnerable
one way or one thing that happens a lot
is that because
in front of house it really is
intentionally to be understaffed so all
the work you have to finish and it is by
default it is really the staff members
responsibility to finish the work so
what what can we do so so the this what
the way the staff members needs to do is
really to invite members to do that and
so and then the variability the need of
our ability is to be able to be okay
with rejections so for example like I I
was assigned and once that you make the
water picture for lunch and it's
actually a sizeable serving actually
usually we have about a hundred you know
serve 100 meal during the lunch time so
usually people will prepare maybe 1218
water features and you know it it
doesn't work well if I just do it by
myself so I have to invite members to
help me so when I go there and I say
could you help me to make the pictures
and I maybe would say no and I'm
thinking what do you mean no no I mean
that they also didn't say that but you
know obviously it hurts but the thing is
you know unless I mean this is really
the opportunity for me to think about
okay why the person say no to me it
hurts a little bit of your for a few
seconds but you know it's a it's really
an indication to me to say you know
first of all maybe I don't have another
relationship with this individual no no
they have the full right to say no to me
or maybe the winner in vitam is not
quite right maybe I didn't explain what
is involved in this work how long it
takes and you know I'm going to work
with you I didn't say that so it is a
moment of reflection for the for the
staff member
to think through what you know what no
really are talking about and it also is
an environment that for the staff
members to be very not only reflective
but we take the responsibility to be
responsible for the know and not to put
the plan on the member who say no to you
but to think of the way that you can do
better so the wilderness to take that
more ability helps to create tours who
really up ho members you know exercising
of their autonomy they are free to say
no and this is for real they are free to
say no and you have we have to be able
to support that by by the welding us to
be vulnerable in that way and it's
required oh all the way through the
house and the other part that is and I
it's very certainly very very true to me
is that I'm actually very new person to
the house everything I learned new was
told by a member so I taught I actually
learned how to use commercial dishwasher
it was called if I remember and I was
helping out doing the the green green
house and and learned how to check the
chemicals in the water and I know how to
fix it and it's a very meticulous
process it was taught by a member and so
for every staff member and it's not just
me and I was the I had the fortune to
watch some men some staff members switch
unit so the host of the worker is
totally new to that person and what had
a fortune to observe the same man the
staff member even though he or she had
been in the house for a while but the
tests are new so the person has to ask
for help from the member as member to
show them how to do those work and that
gives people the opportunities to really
remembers especially to be the aspirin
and now way too
use the power differential so that's
actually a very very interesting aspect
of the work and it requires a lot of
self awareness from the staff members
and the other part is to model the
management of relational boundaries and
before we are talking about this is
actually a very social environment and
and I think it's very interesting to see
how staff members sort of figure out how
to identify the boundaries and now
there's no books to hide behind as a
leader it's only minimum like boundary
rules and that's that it's being spelled
out so and the reason for that is also
to really see members as coworkers
this is a working environment this is a
working community so they are not
patients they are not clients it's
really they are they are working with
you and you have to figure out how you I
didn't how you decide that that
boundaries and that creates a lot of
interesting dynamics and it really puts
the staff member on the spot a lot and
what member wanted your phone number and
how you're gonna deal with it and I saw
very interesting examples where the
staff members has to figure out you know
how themselves really feel about it so
that you have to go to your own feelings
and believe or not it can be very
complicated it's about how you see your
work role how you see your personal
preference how you see the other person
in front of you and it's all that all
together of all those assessment and you
know deliberations that come to that
answer and how you respond to the other
person and if there's something them
just to be told what I heard is a lot of
awkward moments and how you're going to
manage that awkward moments how you make
it become a learning moment for both
parties and that's that's the way that
we mean they require
staff to use himself right there and he
also promotes positivity which one it
means is that a lot of opportunities are
in the house where the staff members can
provide encouragement and as I saw a lot
of examples of like in the meetings they
go through our review data so there's
usually two meanings in the house one in
the morning services out the day and why
in the afternoon so to review what's
being done in the morning what needs to
be done in the afternoon so especially
in the afternoon meetings there's lots
of like praises two people have finished
the task suicide to them and it's a very
public uplifting experience to be there
and so I always say so-and-so you did a
great job on that thank you for helping
me doing that so and then you know and
someone would say so-and-so I cannot do
this without you and it's a very very
public place of the person's
contribution and the other part and
which i think is actually very
interesting is the staff are giving the
opportunities to really make good use of
humor whining thematically example is
that so I was one I mean next to a staff
member who was inviting a member to do
some data interpreter and the member
literally takes like a second it's not
very don't funny it was wrong when you
are waiting for a response and then just
about the time that she and I thought
that he might just reject and he said
okay I'll give it a try
and so it was sort of a heightened
attention right there but the staff
member you say opportunity to say
something so when you know use some
humor and she said to him that I'm glad
that you can really take some time to
think it carefully before you say yes so
and I see this these kind of examples a
lot in the house that the good use of
humor is really a way to defuse some
tensions
taketake no make no mistakes it sounds
like a very positive and a jacking
environment but it is also very
stressful on the staff members side and
also members maybe so it really takes
the the staff member to be to be able to
know how to make a positive spin on
things all the time and and family and
it is about you know developing
individualized relationship and now what
I found interesting is that this is an
environment that encourage everybody to
be as authentic as possible said so
you're actually saying you don't have to
you know for members members don't have
to love every staff member vice versa so
7 Arizona don't have to love every
member and and this really creates and
you know healthy environment was good
support around everybody and so and it
also allows to devour individualize the
relationship so for some members a staff
member may think that they can really
you know develop more co social
relationship and also even friendship
and for some members that perhaps they
really are sort of focusing on work
relationship and have a very effective
and work very effectively and and but
for each individual they are cannot have
the opportunities to experience
different kind of relationship in this
community and that provides the variety
of experiences in this environment to
okay and the other part about community
building is the staff members actually
has to have their attention on a lot of
different things and this is actually
doing a disservice to sort of a dissect
them into three three areas because they
are really intertwined but for the
purpose of articulation I try to you
know sort of sort them into
social connections work order day and
the individual needs and so a staff
member really has to simultaneously
attend 203 area altogether so it takes a
lot of ability capacity to a coordinate
and the other part is to facilitate
community identity and one day do that
it is really together with members who
are already there to orient new staff
members and new members in terms of what
funding house is about and they do a lot
through actually before we have heard
modeling conversing really just talk
about what from the house is about and
trying to share experiences and trying
to show show what is really like and so
in a way to facilitate the development
of a community identity and trying to
come in from a house to outside
community and staff members are and I
actually as a whole I think what I heard
from staff members and other people in
some house is that near is a very clear
idea that from the house is not one shop
for all it actually has a very strong
linkage to outside communities for a lot
of things for education needs for that
for me for transitional employment
because the opportunities out there for
me outside how that's what it's for
and also for a lot of times for
individuals needs
for example they some individuals some
members do need therapy
they do need treatment and it is a it's
being encouraged that the members will
seek out those type of services and help
outside of from the house and so from
the house it has a very clear position
or situated within the larger community
and that's actually very important for
staff members to recognize it and to be
able to really good you make good use of
the community resources as well and to
orchestrate moments to ensure flow of
work because those are three intro
credit areas and so for the staff
members they really have to be able to
make sure the flow goes and I think one
very quick analogy is it's like working
in your restaurant you have to make your
customer happy and comfortable and you
have to organize with other waiters and
waitresses just so that you know things
are being covered and you have to go
back to the kitchen just to make sure
that food is made exactly the way that
you know people want and this is
actually not an analogy that I came up
with it's actually from the interview
that stephanie was shared with me and
therefore anything work with a staff
member and other members in each other
organizations I actually very much
impressed about the flexibility and
openness of fountain house and he really
allows the diversity in staff
composition and task development and the
by diversity I'm not saying really about
demography McGrath Creek diversity that
is there too but I'm saying more in
terms of the characteristics that before
I described people can be loud can be
quiet and can be extroverts tension can
be introverts and can bring in different
kind of expertise hidden talents to the
place and it's no longer hidden believe
me and that staff actually have
opportunities to do to come up with
programs that fits in their interests
and talents too and then it also
stimulates learning through mutual
observation so everything is actually
out in the open when ice and think very
interesting about this place is that
there is a very limited space that's
behind the closed door so every activity
is interactions are out in the open and
I think that really really facilitates
modeling and observation and I
personally also learned a lot about from
how the practices by just sitting there
and watch and so that's actually a very
interesting aspect
of this organization and also all can
contribute accrued into strengths so
like I described this staff members
alike and so I think there is
we have film directors among members we
have you know a carpenter among staff
members and so everybody get the
opportunity to showcase what they know
and to share their their assets to the
community and they really provide
individualized care what I means is that
just like John was describing recovery
is very personal and you describe that
to it very personalized it really up to
the person to decide what it means to to
recover and so what they consider as
success is not necessarily like some
programs that you have to be sober you
know after this amount of treatment it's
really about you know last week I came
to the house to day away two days a week
and this week I'm trying I'm gonna try
three days that's a success and you know
in the past years you know I only come
to the house maybe I will try I wanted
to try just traditional employment next
month that's a success
and you know last year when I come here
I only work in this unit I only know
these five four or five people and you
know I wanted to explore a little bit
more I want to go to another unit and to
see you know if I can make new friends
that success
and so it's it's really a very very
individualized idea and and and and
that's that the difference between where
they were and what where they are is a
success and that's the outcome that can
that actually I think it's very hard to
measure scientifically but it is very
meaningful qualitatively family
intentionality its I this is actually
also something that I found very very
impressed by the organization is is how
a program idea can be so consistently
reflected on the design
of the problem itself so the idea is for
the members who feel need to feel being
needed and so there is infrastructure to
have understaffed design and so staff
are encouraged to involve members just
so they can make make things work and
then when it comes to evaluation it's
not about whether the job is done it's
about how the job is being done so I for
example I was asked to you know do you
know the way when I was in the unit they
are trying to get that they are in Union
and news later out and the so the unit
leader can't come to either checking
with me and she was not asking me that
well for me have you finished or
finished all the the envelopes and put
in the newsletter in the envelopes she
came to ask me how did you get your work
done and what she focused on is whether
I did it by myself which is totally
wrong
or I did it with the involvement or
members so in other words it's so and
think our Father places and we all have
these experiences where you know the
mission of that organization may say
that I really respect clients but then
you see there are separate bathrooms for
staff workers and then for a client
what does I really say but I think we
don't see and alright I don't see that
in at founding house everything is very
very consistent and that has that in
interpreting yet and so I actually like
to think of from the house as a
organization with us all and it's really
a organism that every parts of the the
working fits very well work well
together and I think that really gives
us a lot to think about and how we can
improve our other environments no thank
you
so I guess we are questions and it sent
me thinking about look and pay to say
was it
was more usage clubs the word clunk was
very in contemporary in the contemporary
lesson I think that your club house is
most often used in sports at least
weaselly baseball that's right
and though the authority relations in
the sports club house
- fountain house say baseball coach the
coach is the boss right and the players
have to do what the boss says but
forgetting that it's we doing that as an
exception the contemporary baseball or
soccer club house is one or Club is one
in which the teamwork is completely
essential and where people have a
variety of different roles each has to
perform his or her well for the whole
team
it's actually had to in writing the book
it was a major issue because this
anonymous association between club house
and people said we're both the same the
problem with that as far as we're
concerned is that there's a lot of love
houses out there that have nothing to do
with what we're talking about and so we
felt and actually from from a practice
point of view when I deal with youth
club houses I encourage them to be very
careful about using the word club house
because the people they go to associate
for the old-fashioned people sitting
around you know playing games because
that's what they saw in the clubhouse
that they were associated with right so
as a matter of fact I I do not find
people who associate a clubhouse with
athletic clubs and the discipline of a
clubhouse they look from my experience
it's very undisciplined and therefore a
very poor word to use and as a model I'm
not entirely I think community is the
money you know task groups and then from
a broader perspective community is is
the real model underneath it all is what
we're really trying to get at is it's
not work just work and doing things
together it's how you do these think the
quality of the intervention I have to
tell you she she's really hard to
something with this in the work of study
instead of studying the members
study the staff and I remember the day
that I had to give up my face in order
to survive there and was Esther you
gotta come clean with me merely I had to
pay for all their drinks parade I kept
saying no I don't do that but I knew she
was right but it's very interesting idea
of having a face I came from people
didn't have doors to their website at
door right this way you can't have
professions great ability of faces so
they don't really have to relate on an
authentic plant which is just a John is
saying what really meaningful if I work
with somebody if they're authentic to me
I'm better you know and I'm getting that
across to me so and Club doesn't do it
so in the book it's it's it's not
mentioned at all in fact one of the
readers like I don't know
University Press put me through this
gauntlet and and one of the readers was
really angry to no end that I had not
used the word Clubhouse and some of us
you know is trying to be dishonest to
everybody and and I just said well I'm
not doing it I mean I just said well
yeah
or this but there is that sense out
there the clubhouse is the word that I
just I firmly believe that's not the
word it's the wrong word its
associations are not disciplined
Clubhouse that's like you're being you
know soccer teams but nilly places that
are hardly disciplined and do not show
the and really do not go after this idea
of relationships right that we have to
establish relationships in with people
who have mental notes because that's
what they don't have that's what that's
what's lacking and just sending people
out into society without support and
they end up by isolating those who go to
school
I said a quick comment I guess it's kind
of in question what is thank you for
your comment because I also felt very
long did a social worker my very first
job within the psychiatric hospital
during right before I started right
before the institutionalization so watch
that whole process so what I'm going to
become out that evolution video tips
given who the most remarkable things for
me about this model and that is that
this path leads to sustain and evolve
and maintain the integrity of this what
you call this organism it kind of mold
fall through almost a century of
evolution of policies and prejudices and
of programs and of professional
education so there has to be something
else that I think things that women
deeply at the kernel which protection of
these weak to my question which is about
defending I do a lot of work
internationally I just actually came
back from Moldova where there they are
looking for mister I gave an actually
the citation to your book yeah but the
point a thank you there of course that
I'm curious how the in in moving the
model to other parts of the world how
it's been how how it is consciously or
consciously adapted to different
cultures different context different and
I get the European more maybe than in
the Western model maybe more than some
of the other some of the other regions
of the world so I just wonder if you
think - well the model was really picked
up primarily through Scandinavia and I
am I'm appealing I thought once thought
it was religious because it was you know
there's a dividing line the Protestant
Catholic and they weren't we weren't in
southern Europe and many more than that
but now I think it's really not religion
it's more language that we were so
America English base and the skin and
Amiens joke in English the Italians do
not speak any German stone French don't
all these groups are not so I'm more I'm
saying okay when you go into a European
context though it's sort of easy to do
this is there's social money it's even
there's more money socially than there
is in the United States and there's
certain adaptations that have - now it's
gone to places like Japan which has not
been successful at replicating it's very
small but South Korea has there's a
upwards of 20 to 25 Club houses in South
Korea
and so but I think that organizationally
South Korea did it right so I I don't
know if this time you don't might take
us a little while to talk but I think
that there are certain trees thin link
South Korea Massachusetts where
organizationally it happened so it
wasn't the idea of the model which
morehouse implemented that I think for
stirred its development reality is we're
not in Africa we're not in South the
Arab would only have one two three four
ounces in Argentina so we're not in
broad areas where and there's yes enough
people I mean
so there's a real question about how
it's been replicated which i think is a
really important question and I believe
because we focused on the idea the idea
is compelling doesn't matter where you
go
the idea is fun none of that you need to
be needed that you know you need to be
and now it's going to be the original
title but if that's what's
cross-cultural you know and and so we
sort of took that and what we being the
broad history of thousand houses that
are people who invented them so that
took that and tried to figure out how do
you do that and so in an oversight but I
think if you're gonna talk about the
spread of the model I think you get into
a whole different discussion it's not
the ideas compelling but you have to
think about it organizationally and how
how innovation then you really get into
innovation and I believe it is once
again goes back to late how do you
organize groups within you know and
advocacy groups and things of that
nature that's suggested because I've
learned working in Kazakhstan and
they're talking about all these people
in montalvo you could talk to them
things like that